peu la crise de bizerte continue aux
abords de la médina qui selon certaines
rumeurs se transformerait encore tranché
les éléments tunisien reste le doigt sur
la gâchette
[Musique]
de l'autre côté de la rue les français
veulent aussi derrière leurs abris
et les chars continuent de garder les
issues
pendant quelques jours le ravitaillement
a manqué boulangerie à siéger dans la
ville européenne camions de pain à
siéger dans la médina
il semble qu'aujourd'hui tout soit
rentré dans l'ordre et que le
ravitaillement se fasse à peu près
normalement
et même il y a quelques fois entre les
adversaires d'hier comme un essai de
souris c'est dans ce climat devait y
d'armes que monsieur h invité par
monsieur bourguiba est venu selon ses
propres paroles se mettre à la
disposition du gouvernement tunisien
le secrétaire général des nations unies
effectué ce voyage à titre personnel
sans avoir reçu de l'onu une quelconque
mission
[Musique]
c'est cependant sous le couvert du
pavillon onusien que monsieur h qui
d'abord ne devait pas y aller
décida soudain de se rendre à bizerte
[Musique]
et voici l'incident la voiture de
monsieur en marche elle avait franchi
sans encombre le premier barrage
français au second barrage
les parachutistes l'arrêt puis le
l'installer l'incident a duré 30
secondes mais on en parlera partout et
nous serons bien sûr que monsieur h à
rencontrer des unités françaises sur son
chemin mais nous ne savons pas si
monsieur h à jeter un regard sur les
tranchées tunisienne creuser pour
encercler la base cause première de la
crise de bizet
[Musique]
du côté français l'amiral anne ont
résidé devant les cercueils des 25
soldats tombés au combat
une brève cérémonie les corps seront
demain transporté en terre française
a new york la nouvelle plainte de la
tunisie réuni 7 à nouveau le conseil de
sécurité cette séance devait se dérouler
sans la participation de la france
aucune nouvelle recommandation ne devait
d'ailleurs en sortie mais la crise de
bizerte n'est pas finie et l'arrivée à
marseille d'un millier de français
fuyant bizerte et le signe concret d'une
inquiétude générale que fuient ces
pauvres gens qui n'en portent avec eux
leur vie libre imad futur l'arrestation
possible
l'internement ou plus encore le retour
du drame absurde
[Musique]
côte à côte sur les quais de toulon deux
étranges navy le premier est tout
simplement le bathyscaphe qui plongea à
4050 m le second son successeur qui se
nomme archimède aura des possibilités
infiniment plus grande puisque il
descendra ça se faire à la profondeur de
11000 mètres et que des hélices lui
permettant de se mouvoir et de se
diriger
voici donc un instrument de grande
classe pour l'exploration des gouffres
de l'océan et le commandant ho l'un de
ses promoteurs peut ambitionner d'ores
et déjà le titre d'explorateurs des
grands fonds ou stop nautique georges
vallerey championnats de france de
natation 1961 dans le 100 m nage libre
la course sera serrée entre gérard grau
pèse un nageur de 18 ans à peine et le
tenant du titre
alain got vallès finalement gros pèse à
la ligne numéro 4 l'un portera en 57
secondes 2/10 battant god vallès d'un
dixième de seconde de balès et groupe f
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
surprise dans la finale du 100 m nage
libre dames marie-laure gaillot à la
ligne numéro 4 gagnera nettement en 8
minutes 5 secondes 8/10 et battra la
championne de france et d'afrique
[Musique]
et la france est la première à féliciter
la nouvelle champions
[Applaudissements]
dans le 100 m papillon championnat la
ligne numéro 4 ratera le record de
france en une minute 5 secondes
coma qui se détachera après le virage va
résister au retour désespéré de
jean-pierre moines qui se classera
second ayant sans doute produit son
effort un peu trop tard
[Applaudissements]
sur un visage de gosse le sourire du
vainqueur à yu xin gong qu'on surnomme
poétiquement la ville de l'aurore on à
célébrer joyeusement la fête de l'eau
qui est la principale solennité du
nouvel an ces réjouissances se
caractérise par une aspersion mutuelle
qui tient lieu de nos formules de
meilleurs voeux
et les visiteurs de marque que recevait
la ville à ce moment messieurs chou et
l'ail premier ministre de chine et où
nous premier ministre de birmanie n'ont
pas fait de difficultés pour se joindre
aux joyeuses arroseurs et arrosé
ces petites maisons de bois sont les
habitations d'une étrange tribu de
l'inde descendants des soldats
d'alexandre juif rescapé de la captivité
de babylone le mystère entoure ce peuple
des taux das réduit à 500 à peine
aujourd'hui étrange personnage barbu est
doté d'un d'anchamps pour la méditation
le travail avilissant leur étant
interdit
[Musique]
quant aux femmes chacune à plusieurs
maris
vitol de goli chez pierre grand bac qui
ont rapporté ces images des auteurs du
nil guiry ont assisté à la plus
singulière des cérémonies tôt das les
funérailles d'une jeune femme de 20 ans
[Musique]
sa montagne les jeunes gens sont allés
capturer les buffles sauvage consacré au
dieu n 12 buffle qu'un prêtre assommera
pour que la ram qui épure se chargent
des péchés de la morte
alors commence au milieu des
gémissements des pleureuses
la deuxième partie de la cérémonie
l'incinération du cada un jour viendra
sans doute ou le dernier toda
disparaîtra et l'on considérera ces
images à la lumière de ce fait comme le
témoignage d'un instinct d'autant plus
précieux qu'il va périr
[Musique]